Let's go next to our caller from the two five,
four area code.
Who's calling today from two five four.
Hi, David.
This is Leon from Austin.
Hey Leon.
Great show.
Hey listen, I have a several questions, but
I had to pick one and maybe a day.
Other ones or two other ones for another show.
And he's about Stephen Miller and the whole
issue and, um, Jesco about, uh, what is going
on with the student Miller and the white nationalist.
And I do.
I do, however, have an insight on the person
who asks you how many countries could potentially
trunk with meddling with uh, no, he's a Russian
now for hating Ukraine is because they spoke
badly about him.
They don't like him.
And so we're going to count all the countries
that don't like him.
One example,
that's a big list,
right?
You know, it's possible England, England may
have interfere with elections as well,
but I think that Carla was asking where Trump
is interfering, not if England interfered,
but if Trump is interfering [inaudible] right.
I know, I know.
I know.
Um, well, uh, are we getting this Stephen
Miller, this is a more serious and very delicate
issue, this allegations about his interaction
and his, uh, find autism for white nationalism
that's been brought up to him before and he,
his defense was actually going to an immediate
attack saying that, how dare you do that?
How much you and my family survived the Holocaust
and blah, blah, blah.
And many people actually were afraid of bringing
this up in the past because of that issue.
And that answer that he had as lying that
he use now, um, is said the whole cost is
something very horrible that indeed happened
and many Jews fled during and survivors after
and most of them came to America.
And you know, when I say America, I'm talking
about the continent in general and, and with
uh, nothing, absolutely nothing.
Yeah.
I mean it's like, it's like my family that
went from, uh, from Eastern Europe to Argentina
with nothing.
Yeah.
However, there is a few and luckily a few
that are actually for unknown reasons and
that has been explored.
Scape, quartered, I'm quoted, but actually
with a lot of them only, and they have been
investigations and gotten by groups that also,
you know, there were some Jews.
So Leon, let me put a pause in the direction
you're going because I don't, but I don't,
I'm not saying you're going to do this, but
you may be about to go in a very, very ugly
direction.
But let me tell you this, Jews are, for the
most part, very liberal.
They have been on the forefront of the civil
rights movement in the United States and in
other places.
They are widely targets of white nationalism,
but there are also people of any group, regardless
of their identity, Jews included like Stephen
Miller, who are absolutely outrageous reactionaries
and the fact that they, if they attack identity
politics, which they do, they shouldn't be
at the same time be able to hide behind their
identity as Stephen Miller has sometimes tried
to do.
I think that's how I would contextualize it.
Yeah, I mean, and I totally agree.
I mean religion has nothing to do with those
extreme idealisms that you can profess that,
but nobody seemed to be able to put it together
and you know, put him in his place to answer
that.
Well, listen, Leon, I appreciate the question
where, where are you from originally?
Where are you from originally?
My friend,
well, I'm originally from, I was born in Argentina
actually, but I,
you know, I suspected that from your accent.
I have, I am regularly around people from
Argentina who speak English and I am not surprised
to hear you say that from window Situs or
somewhere else.
Yeah, when Cyrus, but I actually left when
Cyrus, when I was five years old, he moved
to Peru and uh, where I spent quite a bit
of time there.
All right, Leon, I appreciate the phone call.
Maybe the first a fellow Argentinian that
has called in man, which I had asked.
Yes.
Alright.
You want me to do
okay.
All right.
We'll talk to you very, very soon.
We will Mark him a very, very high in the
call scoring.
Of course.